[Music]
maybe somebody can help me
maybe i need help because i don't know
how you're on like a steady progression
from you know kind of okay to like
really good to really really good to
this
phantom menace
that was bad that was bad i'm just gonna
straight up that was bad
let's get into all the reasons why that
was just not
good at all first of all this little kid
should have been like 15. i'm sorry i i
don't want to see
a little kid accidentally destroy a
space station
that was stupid that was just dub i'm
sorry i'm being like kind of aggressive
and mean but it's like
this is really really bad and i don't
understand why and it's very
and it's very perplexing why it's so bad
even ellen mcgregor who's a great actor
was bad in this
i don't understand can i just say that
the problem
inherently i feel like with prequels is
that you already know where the story is
going
that's why i did need to see a star trek
enterprise
i didn't need to see a star trek
discovery it's about
strange new worlds explore new things go
forward
i i tend to not like prequels so that
was already kind of like okay prequels
whatever i would much prefer you
do new stuff and go forward because it's
just going to lead into the place where
we already know it's going to lead
so right so you got this little boy who
can't act
who is really smart and can can create
sentient robots
and pilot this pod racer really well but
he doesn't know what stars are
so like i i don't understand how you're
giving me like okay we got this genius
child
but he's like what are stars how many
stars are there in the galaxy so that
right off the bat
is super annoying and that pod racing
scene just went
on and on and on and on they literally
showed like all three laps i don't need
to see this what is this this is like
trying to sell me toys did they i
guarantee you they sold those like
racer toy cars because that's all that
was it was like a toy commercial
that was like a 10 minute toy commercial
for racing cars
in the middle of a freaking movie which
by the way this movie was like
half a cartoon there is so
much bad cgi i know that is the
distinction because you know a lot of
cgi and movie like whatever
a lot of really really bad cgi is not
okay you know especially when this is
like around the same time
as lord of the rings there's no excuse
for it to look
this ridiculous oh and don't even get me
started on
jar jar binks jar jar binks is like i
know people talk crap about this
character on the internet i've seen it
but it's not just this character his
entire race is annoying
and unneeded why do we need this in this
gigantic
underwater stupid race of cgi animals i
mean
star wars made a name for itself
with all of these practical effects and
you would think
they would do that
and not so much cgi right there was no
there was no need for a lot of this cgi
stuff a lot of this could have just been
practical effects
and i know i know i know i know what
you're going to say there's more
practical effects in these movies than
there is in the other ones
yeah sure but it's also overshadowed by
the terrible cgi
when we get we've got terrible cgi on
top of everything it it
the effect is my eyes are bleeding out
of my freaking eye sockets
right it's not pretty it it hurts it
literally hurts to look at
i feel like hollywood is still learning
this like it almost
never works when you have a fully cgi
character walking around next to
real people it just does not look right
it looks stupid
it looks like i'm watching something
that's half cartoon and that's not what
i'm here for
and i feel like these movies also are
like a tone shift
right uh the original star wars movies
were
you know they weren't like r-rated or
anything but they were a little bit
mature they had some mature ideas and
themes in them
this movie felt like definitely made for
kids this was
definitely just like 100 we're gonna go
all in
this is for children and you know
it's just just so lame
i guess the one kind of cool thing in
the movie was like
darth maul at the end was really cool
like uh he got chopped in half that was
really really crazy
uh so that was cool and also padme's
like you know
double cross thing where she was like
really the other girl the whole time
that was pretty cool um so that was cool
but i mean most of the movie
was pain most of this movie was pain
to get through this was pain like
any time the kid was on screen i'm just
like please
please shut him up i'm like please tell
me he isn't going to be in the next
movie
and he's not thank god because like holy
crap
so natalie portman's character was cool
i guess liam neese's character was
pretty cool um but everyone was just
kind of like middle of the road
nothing really impressed me about this
movie
the explanation about the force and
midichlorians i didn't really understand
it was like see i'm back to being
confused i
went i went from being confused in a new
hub about the force to like kind of
getting it
in empire strikes back and understanding
it and return on the jedi
now i'm [ __ ] confused again what are
we talking about i don't understand
what's happening i don't know
this movie i felt like was kind of a
fail for me
and i just i'm really confused about
what happened
and i'm sorry if i'm like hurting
people's feelings or just like
crushing people but like i just i can't
get behind
phantom menace hopefully attack of the
clones will be better
um but yeah i'm not feeling the start
off to this prequel trilogy so far
this little kid is darth vader
definitely it's very obvious
it's super obvious that this kid's darth
vader you got yoda being like don't
train him
he's like you know what i'm gonna train
him and i'm like maybe you should listen
to
the green alien that knows a lot of
stuff i don't know i don't know i would
have listened to yoda
but whatever so this kid is clearly
going to like go evil
um but whatever it's just that's the
thing about prequels you know where
everything's going
i know where it's going and i barely
know anything about star wars and i know
where it's going
because it's a prequel
don't do pretty cools ah anyway i don't
even want to rate this movie
because it's just like it's gonna i mean
i feel like i'm gonna upset people so
just
i didn't like it i didn't like it let's
leave it at that
i'm sorry i had to come on here and
complain about a movie for 10 minutes
i'm really really sorry you had to sit
through that but you know those are my
honest
thoughts this movie was not enjoyable
for me
maybe if i saw this as a kid i would
have liked it
but seeing this after watching the
original trilogy
this movie does not even come close to
comparing to any of those movies
at all um all three of those movies were
better than this one
by by miles by miles
i mean empire strikes back if a really
really really solid film
and my personal favorite was return on
the jedi although i might
acknowledge that empire strikes back
maybe is slightly more solid than return
but this is just a drop off in quality
that i just i like i said i don't get
sorry um but we'll get into the other
ones thanks guys for watching make sure
you like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas and while you're here
follow me on twitter i'm on a quest to
get to 30
000 followers on twitter in 2021 i'm
like half that much right now but if you
guys
just click the link in the description
for me and hit that follow button you
can see all my interesting endings on
twitter please do it please do it
thank you guys so much and i'll talk to
you guys later peace